of course a lot of shows like mine of
feature stand-up comedians we've been
trying to figure out how to do that one
a very talented stand-up came up with an
idea on just how to do it and he's
joining us right now via zoom John Doerr
Johnny you there
hi Conan I apologize I was hoping to be
back home so I could be in a private no
you already have a lollipop but we're at
the grocery store and the social
distancing lines definitely held things
up a bit but I think we have a quiet
spot in the car here and everything
should be fine so let's tell some jokes
shall we um I was wondering this if
you're a meth addict and you still live
at home of your parents you're probably
making a killing from the tooth fairy
right no you have a lollipop I'm gonna
put you on mute for a second sorry Emma
you gotta shut up all right
please no no no no you be quiet you be
quiet you listen okay you say one more
word I'm gonna take your bike apart
throw it in the forest do you understand
good
ah John you're still on mute
oh there we go okay that's better okay
quiet quiet please
this one by the way weird pre virus I
take her to the grocery store she wants
to batch she wants a Ken doll which he's
not allowed to have so she's on my
shoulders we're checking out of the girl
she's hurt she's furious she hangs our
head down in front of me that says if
you don't get me a Ken doll I'm gonna
kill my mom yeah and then she hangs her
head down as it for emphasis and says to
me I'm going to kill your girlfriend
remember that I don't know what to say I
just told her I said I will not tell
your mom you said that if you don't tell
her about my girlfriend right both
learning about secrets and how to keep
them anyway
oh yeah my dad
[Music]
you buddy you what they'll censor it
don't worry they can censor these words
oh so my father got a blood test back
and that is it turns out he's
pre-diabetic I don't know if you know
what it means to be pre-diabetic but if
you're diagnosed is pre-diabetic it
means you do not have diabetes my dad
was diagnosed with not having anything I
mean we're all pretty diabetic aren't we
we were born pre-diabetic some of us are
lucky enough to die before we get it
hell I'm pre HIV while we're talking
about it and oh my god that guy's coming
back that guy did a u-turn he's coming
after us
all right corner I'm gonna have to get
going I think it was fun checking in
with you and thanks for having me on the
show yeah that is him all right we're
out of here okay you can see more of
John and Emma on John's Instagram at TVs
John Doerr and have a terrific weekend
again stay safe whatever the heck that
means these days and we'll see you on
Monday
bye bye okay Emma we might have to run a
red light